es decir la decisión simbólicamente más
compleja del mandato de pedro sánchez
frontal lo indultara los nueve líderes
independentistas encarcelados tras el
referéndum unilateral de independencia
de cataluña de 2017 ingresaron en
prisión provisional vamos a iniciar las
sesiones del juicio oral en febrero de
2019 arrancaron tres meses de juicio
durante el cual ninguno de los
procesados expresó arrepentimiento
finalmente el 14 de octubre del mismo
año el tribunal supremo emitió las
sentencias condenatorias por delitos de
malversación y sedición resolución que
incendió las calles de barcelona oriol
junqueras quien era vicepresidente
catalán fue condenado a 13 años de
prisión creo sinceramente que lo mejor
para todos sería devolver la cuestión al
terreno de la política de la buena
política
jordi turull que ocupaba el cargo de
consejero de la presidencia raúl romeva
consejero de exteriores y dolors bassa
consejera de asuntos sociales fueron
condenados a 12 años de prisión la ex
presidenta del parlamento catalán karma
forcadell
fue sentenciada a 11 años y seis meses
de prisión también se condenó a diez
años
y seis meses de prisión a los ex
consejeros de interior y de territorios
joaquim forn y josep rull todos fueron
inhabilitados para ejercer cargos
públicos en la misma causa fueron
procesados y condenados los activistas
jordi sánchez y jordi kuhs art cuyas
penas de nueve años de prisión han sido
las más señaladas por organizaciones
internacionales al no ocupar cargos
públicos en el momento de los hechos
sino la dirección de organizaciones de
la sociedad civil
la medida no aplica el entonces
presidente catalán carles puigdemont que
sigue exiliado en bélgica y no ha sido
juzgado por la justicia española o
cataluña
erving y un estat independent en forma
de república los indultos abren una
nueva etapa de diálogo entre madrid y
barcelona pero no resuelven las demandas
de autodeterminación del pueblo catalán
y por otro lado plantean la incógnita
sobre la futura hoja de ruta del
movimiento independentista que desde
2017 ha reclamado libertad para los que
considera prisioneros políticos